libertarians regardless of what they say
when they're sort of spelling out the
abstract of ideas of their philosophy
when they try to convince people of
libertarianism they do it by talking
about the way in which free markets make
life better for the poor my name is Matt
Zielinski I'm an associate professor of
philosophy here at the University of San
Diego and co-director of the Institute
for law and philosophy here I'm also the
founder of the bleeding heart
libertarians blog a bleeding heart
libertarian is somebody who like all
libertarians believes in free markets
believes in private property individual
liberty strictly limited government one
of the things that's distinctive about
bleeding-heart libertarianism is that it
takes a commitment to social justice to
be a core element in the justification
of libertarianism that's why we believe
in libertarianism and free markets in
private property so if you believe in
social justice what you believe then is
that if political and economic
institutions do not allow the poor and
vulnerable members of society to live
decent lives then that counts against
counts strongly against the Justice of
those institutions but simply being
committed to social justice does not
mean that you're committed to the view
that government must directly try to
promote the well-being of the poor and
vulnerable members of society one of the
great insights of libertarians and this
is something that we bleeding-heart
libertarians don't disagree with it all
is that the welfare of the poor and
vulnerable is often better promoted by
lays a fair if it turned out that we
were absolutely wrong about all of this
we'd give up libertarianism we don't
think that's very likely to happen what
might be likely to happen though is that
you could demonstrate that under some
circumstances completely free markets
that is 0 government intervention in the
economy 0 government assistance to poor
or working people it might be possible
to demonstrate that that is worse from
the perspective of social justice than
something
lightly more expanded right so a state
with a social safety net that provided
some relief for poor who couldn't
support themselves on the market or find
support from voluntary charity so I
think there's an openness among
bleeding-heart libertarians to a social
safety net and again here we're online
with I think the mainstream of the
libertarian intellectual tradition if
you look at people like Adam Smith or
John Locke Friedrich Hayek Milton
Friedman all of them supported some kind
of social safety net some minimal role
of government beyond merely protecting
the rights the negative libertarian
rights of its citizens there's two kinds
of things we're trying to do with this
blog in terms of outreach to the left
one of them is a kind of strategic goal
right just winning political allies for
liberty where we can find them but most
of us are academic philosophers or
political theorists and political
strategy is not really are a strong suit
so a bigger part of what we're trying to
do on this blog is really just an
intellectual exercise we're trying to
develop the ideas and follow the ideas
where we think they lead us and I think
if you look at the kinds of core ideas
of libertarianism what it is that drives
people to libertarianism right what you
find is that a lot of those ideas are
shared by the left libertarians
regardless of what they say when they're
sort of spelling out the abstract of
ideas of their philosophy when they try
to convince people of libertarianism
they do it by talking about the way in
which free markets make life better for
the poor the way in which days expand
opportunities for all people not just
the privileged few and so that idea is
doing some real work in the
philosophical justification of
libertarianism even in people who don't
acknowledge it even in people I think
like an R and or Robert Nozick and we're
trying to latch onto those ideas show
that they're an important building block
in the justification of libertarianism
and then follow to them to their
conclusion where do those ideas really
lead what direction philosophically do
they push libertarianism in if we
recognize them and take them to their
logical conclusion
so it's been a surprisingly positive set
of reactions on to the blog as a whole
libertarians have mostly reacted fondly
there are some libertarians who are
strongly opposed to the idea of social
justice and think that any attempt to
sort of reconcile with that particular
concept which is of course traditionally
associated with the political left is
misguided conceptually incoherent
strategically bankrupt or what have you
but I think that's a minority reaction
most people have thought it's a good
thing too it's a nice philosophical
development and and a good outreach to
people who are potential allies to
libertarians there's a kind of moderate
left which has been very receptive to
the ideas they've I don't know that
they've changed their mind on the
minimum wage laws I don't know if
they've changed their nine down
sweatshop labor it's not obvious that
people's minds can change on those
issues simply by being exposed to a few
philosophical arguments on a blog but
they're receptive to the idea that
libertarians aren't as they imagine them
to be these cold-hearted beasts who will
sort of cling to their wallets in the
face of a starving child who needs a few
pennies to get by for the next day I
think they've they've recognized that
libertarians are different than that
that libertarians really do take issues
of social justice seriously we just have
very different thoughts about what it
would take in terms of public policy to
achieve the same results that a lot of
people on the Left say they want
I think there is a subset of
libertarianism that is really opposed to
this idea of bleeding heart
libertarianism it does have more in
common with I think the popular
perception of libertarians as
indifferent to issues of social justice
I think you find elements of that in
Iran I think you find perhaps more of
that in someone like Murray Rothbard
historically maybe you'd pick out
Herbert Spencer but I think that's an
aberration that's not the mainstream of
the libertarian intellectual tradition
so if you look back at the people that
libertarians have picked out as
intellectual icons people like John
Locke people like Adam Smith people like
Friedrich Hayek or Milton Friedman none
of these people reject social justice
all of them talk about the way in which
free markets serve the interests of the
poor and working classes and all that I
think when you look closely at their
texts make that an important element
again in the justification of
libertarianism of why it is that
libertarianism is a good thing
people on the political left have often
thought that capitalism is unjust that
it's exploitative that it's unfair that
it's degrading to workers and
libertarians disagree with those claims
but we don't disagree with the
underlying moral plans we don't disagree
with a claim that it's bad for somebody
to be exploitative right or that it's
bad for somebody to be degraded what we
disagree with is a more empirical claim
it's due markets in fact do that and we
think they don't and we think we have
good empirical evidence that supports
our side of that story so I think
there's room to convince people on the
Left that they're mistaken not in their
fundamental moral commitments
necessarily although libertarians will
have some issues with those as well but
in their empirical belief in their
beliefs about what happens when free
markets operate or whether we have free
markets right now there's this
widespread belief that America is a free
market country and so people on the Left
will sort of point to the United States
and they'll say well look that's what
happens when you have a free market and
this is just false right nobody on the
libertarian movement or the libertarian
intellectual tradition points to the
United States as an icon of what it is
we're trying to achieve there's simply
no good reason to believe that the
axiomatic principles of self-ownership
are as self-evident as rothbard thought
or that we can simply derive out
property rights from those axiomatic
principles as neatly and cleanly as he
thought morality is messy we think there
are a lot of things that we care about
morally speaking we care about justice
we care about autonomy we care about
giving people what they deserve but we
also care about meeting people's needs
there's good reason to want government
to be bound by rules that are in a sense
not reflective of the entire complexity
and nuance of the moral universe you
want government to be governed by clear
and simple and foreseeable rules
people know in advance what they can get
away with without getting into the
clutches of the law
you